we've used drone photography before shot
videos entirely with drones you may have
seen our Superman with a GoPro video or
our pop down shooter but one thing that
we're doing differently here is the tilt
shift effect that makes it sort of
miniature so things in the distance are
really out of focus and basically what
that means for this is just having a
really shallow depth of field
fortunately since the vast majority of
the things in front or behind the main
characters are 3d we could render out
what's called a depth Pass and what you
can do in after-effects is use a plug-in
called fresh looped
depth of field the great fantastic depth
of field plug-in where anything that is
in the distance is pure white anything
that's closer to the camera is pure
black and you have that gradient in
between anything that's white make it
really blur it anything that's pure
black make it really blurry anything
that's middle gray keep that in focus
and so you can dial it in to the exact
amount you want as opposed to doing it
in 3d on some instances where the depth
of field is so shallow it actually
starts luring out the characters we had
to actually rotoscope the characters out
of the shot and place them back in
unblurred so that the background is
blurred out but they are not because
that's how the tilt shift works it's
away from the camera not on a 2d image
we wanted to establish an entire world
and make it feel like we were cruising
around this RTS map exactly so we wanted
to have enough space to put Big Lots and
if you look at the original footage we
have we put down like Red Solo cups to
kind of outline the corners of the
building fortunately the guys who made
game of war sent us a bunch of their
assets that they use to make the models
in the game but they are all completely
untextured they're just like raw
low-quality game models and I took those
and retexture everything in octane
what's great about that is you can see
what the textures look like in real time
it's great so then you lay out all the
buildings open up your live preview
window and you're like yes this looks
great
now time to render good thing it renders
really fast because there are a thousand
frames per shot each renders taking like
15 hours even though it's like 1 to 2
minutes per frame with a thousand frames
that adds up thanks Sam oh and that was
the other thing every shot of Sam's like
alright this video is gonna have the
most effects out of any video so far
this year I'm gonna go get married I'll
see you later
see in two weeks we found the perfect
location and couldn't use it because the
parks are like oh yeah I know this is
the perfect place to fly a drone
you know rules are rules so you can't
you can't fly that stuff here my
expectation was that we're gonna make a
sweet video based off of a classic RTS
genre we're gonna fly a drone around and
track in some buildings and have a
little story the end we really just
needed a wide-open field with lots of
space that will let you fly a drone
there people don't like us flying drones
anywhere got the drone up in the air we
flew around it some test shots worked
flawlessly we use the DG I inspire one
which is pretty much a Corvette on
blades it's the really cool roan that
looks like it's something out of portal
little rectilinear lens on it so you
don't get the nasty GoPro fisheye look
we didn't need to operate the camera we
just set the camera to lock so the roll
is locked Direction is looking is locked
so drone even though it's like doing all
this sort of stuff the camera is locked
at a certain position forward a garden
worker comes up and is like yeah you
can't fly those drones here we're like
can you tell us why it's like cuz you
can't fly them it's like oh well right
what are the rules for that yeah if you
are looking to get into drone technology
and drone flying yourself and you've
never done it before well a great place
to start is amazon.com
they've got drones on there that are
small fun to fly completely harmless and
you can crash them and pick them right
up again yeah they start at like 20
bucks like you can get that little
flying thing you throw it in the air and
fly it away and come back and catch it
for 20 bucks Amazon Prime two days get
it perfect thanks for watching I hope
you guys learn something and thanks to
game of war for making this video
possible if you guys have questions
leave us a comment in the section below
I'm going to regret that